This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 1889, Sigmund Freud was still relatively new in his field. He's what we'd call a pre-Froidian Freud. He was 33 years old and he was working as an assistant to another psychiatrist. And he hadn't had any of his big ideas yet. But he was about to. That's producer Ann Heperman. Freud was mostly practicing hypnosis at the time. It was cutting edge, though still kind of a controversial treatment. So one day Freud gets a new patient. Very wealthy woman, Fannie Moser.
这是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1889年，西格蒙德·弗洛伊德在这一领域还相对资浅。他属于我们所说的“前弗洛伊德时代的弗洛伊德”。当时他33岁，在另一位精神科医生手下担任助理。他还没有提出任何伟大的理论，但很快就要有了。那是制作人安·赫珀曼。弗洛伊德当时主要进行催眠治疗。这在当时是前沿技术，尽管仍是一种颇具争议的疗法。有一天，弗洛伊德迎来了一位新病人，一位非常富有的女士，范妮·莫泽。
That's Michael Roth, president of Wesleyan University, and a Freud historian. Freud's new patient was struggling from all kinds of ailments, hysteria, sleeplessness, pain, and odd ticks. Fannie Moser had lots of doctors. So Fannie Moser would come in and Freud would have her lay down on the couch, just like he did with his other patients. You're honest, you're getting heavy. Freud wasn't the only person using a couch during hypnosis, but he particularly needed it to get people into a more relaxed state. Heavy or unhappier, you're breathing deeper and deeper.
那是卫斯理大学校长、弗洛伊德历史学家迈克尔·罗斯。弗洛伊德的这位新病人正饱受各种疾病的困扰：歇斯底里、失眠、疼痛和奇怪的抽动。范妮·莫泽看过很多医生。范妮·莫泽会走进来，弗洛伊德会让她躺在沙发上，就像对待其他病人一样。你很诚实，你感觉身体沉重。弗洛伊德并不是唯一在催眠中使用沙发的人，但他特别需要它来让人们进入更放松的状态。身体沉重或不快，你的呼吸越来越深。
But he wasn't a very good hypnotist. He was kind of a clumsy hypnotist. So once Moser was on the couch, Freud would be saying, you know, you're getting sleep, you're getting sleep, and she'd be like, no I'm not, I'm not sleepy at all. So while Fanny is laying there, not getting sleepy, she talked. At first, Freud would interrupt her with his theories, but Fanny just wasn't having it.
但他并不是一个很好的催眠师。他是个笨拙的催眠师。所以一旦莫泽躺在沙发上，弗洛伊德就会说，你知道，你快睡着了，你快睡着了，而她会说，不，我没有，我一点也不困。所以当范妮躺在那里，并没有睡着时，她开始说话了。起初，弗洛伊德会用他的理论打断她，但范妮根本不吃这一套。
She wanted to talk. First let me tell you my stories. And then, you know, being the light goes on, Freud has a revelation. If you just let patients talk and don't say anything, they will let down their defenses, and the unconscious will be revealed. This is the moment when the pre-fradiant Freud becomes the Freudian Freud.
她想说话。她说：“先让我讲讲我的故事。”然后，灯光亮起，弗洛伊德有了一个启示。如果你只是让病人说话而不插嘴，他们就会放下防备，潜意识就会显露出来。这就是“前弗洛伊德时代的弗洛伊德”转变为“弗洛伊德式的弗洛伊德”的时刻。
And the Freudian Freud's new techniques and theories for therapy would come to be called psychoanalysis. Most new theories in the world do not get assigned their own piece of furniture but this one ultimately inexorably did, the couch. If psychoanalysis had a flag, oh you know it would have a picture of a couch on it. You can actually go visit Freud's couch. It's in his last home in London. Freud had the couch shipped from Vienna after fleeing the Nazis in 1938. Good call, Sigmund.
而弗洛伊德式的新疗法和理论后来被称为精神分析。世界上大多数新理论都不会有专属的家具，但这个理论最终不可避免地拥有了——那就是沙发。如果精神分析有一面旗帜，你知道上面肯定会有一张沙发的图片。你实际上可以去参观弗洛伊德的沙发。它就在他伦敦最后的住所里。1938年逃离纳粹后，弗洛伊德把沙发从维也纳运了过来。干得好，西格蒙德。
Freud saw patients on his couch right up to his death a year later. We sent our de facto London correspondent, the Illusionist's Helen Zoltzman, to check it out. This is Helen Zoltzman reporting outside from Freud's old study. Freud actually had a couple of couches. But the one we now associate with him was a gift from a patient, a madame Ben Vanisty. She told Freud that if she was going to have her head examined,
弗洛伊德在沙发上接待病人直到一年后他去世。我们派出了事实上的伦敦通讯员、《魔术师》的海伦·佐尔茨曼去一探究竟。这是海伦·佐尔茨曼在弗洛伊德旧书房外报道。弗洛伊德实际上有几张沙发。但我们现在与他联系在一起的那一张，是一位病人本·瓦尼斯蒂夫人送的礼物。她告诉弗洛伊德，如果她要接受心理检查，
she might as well be comfortable. Apparently she found the couch Freud had at the time sorely lacking, so she got him a cozier one. It's really a very cozy looking couch. It's not a clinical looking at all. It looks like a great place to take a nap. Freud studies full of rugs and books and artifacts from other cultures. It has sort of an Indiana Jones vibe to it, and his couch is in keeping with that. It's a Devon style sofa. Some people
那她最好还是舒服点。显然，她觉得弗洛伊德当时用的沙发实在太简陋了，所以她送了他一张更舒适的。那确实是一张看起来非常舒适的沙发。它一点也不像临床设备。它看起来是个打盹的好地方。弗洛伊德的书房里摆满了地毯、书籍和来自其他文化的文物。它有一种印第安纳·琼斯式的氛围，而他的沙发也与此相符。这是一种德文风格的沙发。有些人
might call it a swooning couch, and it's covered in exotic red Persian carpets and piled with velvet pillows. So you can't actually tell what the couch beneath it is really like, whether it's stained with human experience. What's underneath is a surprisingly plain, Jane beige sofa. All clean lines and rectangular forms. It's almost boring. The couch is what's known as a beatomire sofa, a very popular style back when Freud got
可能会称之为“晕厥沙发”，上面覆盖着充满异国情调的红色波斯地毯，堆满了天鹅绒枕头。所以你实际上看不出沙发下面到底是什么样子，也不知道它是否沾染了人类的经历。下面是一张出奇朴素的简易米色沙发。线条简洁，呈长方形。它几乎有点无聊。这种沙发被称为比德迈风格沙发，在弗洛伊德得到它时非常流行，
it in 1891. It was like something you'd find in a Viennese lady's bedroom, domestic. a beat of myrsofa, a very popular style back when Freud got it in 1891. It was like something you'd find in a Viennese lady's bedroom, domestic. A piece of furniture designed for relaxing and dreaming. But the more patience Freud saw on the couch, the more he wrote about those patients. The more the couch became thought of as an essential instrument in Freudian psychoanalysis. Look, the couch was central to the idea of getting to the unconscious. That's Dr. Arnold Richards, a psychoanalyst who practices on New York's Upper East Side.
那是1891年。它就像你在维也纳女士卧室里看到的那种家具，很居家。比德迈风格沙发，在弗洛伊德1891年得到它时非常流行。它就像你在维也纳女士卧室里看到的那种家具，很居家。这是一件专为放松和做梦而设计的家具。但弗洛伊德在沙发上接待的病人越多，他关于这些病人的著作就越多。沙发也越来越被认为是弗洛伊德精神分析中不可或缺的工具。看，沙发是通往潜意识的核心。那是阿诺德·理查兹医生，一位在纽约上东区执业的精神分析学家。
In traditional analysis, Richard says the couch is a tool. A patient lies down on his or her back looking up at the ceiling. You're staring up, you're staring into yourself. You're looking inside, rather than outside. Traditional psychoanalysts believe the couch helps a patient relax and open up and understand their unconscious conflicts and inhibitions like... Why you can't, you know, finish your paper, why you can't work, what are your symptoms and what are your inhibitions and you want to understand that. And that's what psychoanalysis and psychoanalysis therapy is about. And some of these therapists believe that even the placement of the couch, like where it
理查兹说，在传统的分析中，沙发是一个工具。病人仰面躺着，看着天花板。你盯着上方，你是在审视自己。你是在向内看，而不是向外看。传统的精神分析学家认为，沙发有助于病人放松、敞开心扉，并理解他们的潜意识冲突和抑制，比如……为什么你不能完成你的论文，为什么你不能工作，你的症状和抑制是什么，你想理解这些。这就是精神分析和精神分析疗法的意义所在。一些治疗师甚至认为沙发的摆放位置，比如它
is in the room, makes a difference. I know there was one analyst who would put the couch in the middle of the room because he felt that the patient shouldn't be close to a wall, that the wall would make him secure, and he wanted the patient to be insecure, he wanted to promote the regression. The analyst typically sits in a chair out of sight from the patient on the couch, and though some analysts believe this positioning helps the patient feel freer to open up, Freud may have had more selfish reasons.
在房间里的位置，也会产生影响。我知道有一位分析师会把沙发放在房间中央，因为他觉得病人不应该靠近墙壁，墙壁会让他感到安全，而他想要病人感到不安全，他想促进这种退行。分析师通常坐在病人看不见的椅子上，虽然一些分析师认为这种位置有助于病人更自由地敞开心扉，但弗洛伊德可能有更自私的原因。
He once remarked, I cannot put up with being stared at by other people for eight hours a day. In any case, when an object plays such a central role to the work that you do, choosing the right one becomes a big deal. It's like a right of passage. It's like you've made it. Which means good business for the guys making those couches. We had to have a separate factory just to make the couches because we also made sofas
他曾评论道：“我无法忍受每天八小时被别人盯着看。”无论如何，当一个物体在你所做的工作中扮演如此核心的角色时，选择合适的那个就变得非常重要。这就像一种成人礼。这就像你成功了。这意味着制造这些沙发的厂商生意兴隆。我们不得不专门开辟一个工厂来制作这些沙发，因为我们也制造沙发
and club chairs. Fred Braffman used to run Imperial leather furniture company in Queens, New York. It's a family-owned business that's been selling psychoanalytic couches since the 1940s. His father-in-law, Irving Levy, actually patented a version of a psychoanalytic couch he designed with his business partner. Alicia Brafman says her father was extremely proud of it. Every time anybody walked into the store,
和俱乐部椅。弗雷德·布拉夫曼曾经营纽约皇后区的帝国皮革家具公司。这是一家家族企业，自20世纪40年代以来一直在销售精神分析沙发。他的岳父欧文·利维实际上为他和商业伙伴设计的一款精神分析沙发申请了专利。艾丽西亚·布拉夫曼说她父亲对此感到非常自豪。每次有人走进店里，
he'd saunter up to them and say, you know, he would say, we make Freud's couches, which of course they didn't. The couch they sold wasn't Freud's exotic, cozy pile of cushions. Their psychoanalytic couches were like the one you're probably thinking of. Low to the ground, sleek. Braffman sold these psychoanalytic couches all over the country and around the world for decades.
他就会溜达到他们身边说，你知道，他会说，我们制造弗洛伊德的沙发，当然他们并没有。他们卖的沙发并不是弗洛伊德那种充满异国情调、舒适的靠垫堆。他们的精神分析沙发就像你可能想到的那种。离地很低，线条流畅。几十年来，布拉夫曼把这些精神分析沙发卖到了全国各地乃至全世界。
And the psychoanalysts buying them had some particular aesthetics. Most of them were being made in leather. But tuffing with buttons, a big no-no from nervous patients. They would pick at it because they were edgy, nervous, and it would present the maintenance problem. Basically, constructing the perfect psychoanalytic couch is like building a sofa for goldilocks. It can't be too soft, and it can't be too hard.
购买它们的精神分析学家有一些特殊的审美要求。大多数是用皮革制成的。但是带有纽扣的簇绒设计，对紧张的病人来说是大忌。他们会因为焦躁不安而抠弄它，这会带来维护问题。基本上，打造完美的精神分析沙发就像为金发姑娘制作沙发一样。它不能太软，也不能太硬。
So we used to use a special spring and special cotton and horse hair, hog hair, combination to make it the, as they said, just right. Fred's business boomed in the 40s, 50s and early 60s. What some have called the Golden Age of Psycho Analysis. It was very good. It was a very good business. But then in the late 60s, things changed. People started to experiment with alternative therapies
所以我们过去使用特殊的弹簧、特殊的棉花和马毛、猪毛混合物，使它达到他们所说的“恰到好处”。弗雷德的生意在40年代、50年代和60年代初蓬勃发展。有些人称之为精神分析的黄金时代。非常好。那是一门非常好的生意。但到了60年代末，情况发生了变化。人们开始尝试替代疗法，
and the first generation of antidepressants offered faster relief. Traditional psychoanalysis fell out of favor. And you might be able to guess what happened to analytic couch sales. Now, couches aren't being used all that much. They sit up in club chairs or lounge chairs and they talk to the psychoanalyst. And even within psychoanalytic circles, people became less certain that the couch was a good tool. Different schools of thought started cropping up.
第一代抗抑郁药提供了更快的缓解。传统的精神分析不再受欢迎。你可能猜到了分析沙发的销量发生了什么。现在，沙发的使用频率没那么高了。他们坐在俱乐部椅或休闲椅上，与精神分析学家交谈。即使在精神分析圈内，人们也开始不太确定沙发是否是一个好工具。不同的思想流派开始涌现。
Whether or not you use the couch, you know, can determine, you know, what you're doing and why you're doing it and what your theory is. You could say that two camps formed in psychoanalysis. Team couch and team no couch. Some would say it's easier to have a conversation, you know, sitting face to face.
你是否使用沙发，你知道，可以决定你正在做什么，为什么这样做，以及你的理论是什么。你可以说精神分析形成了两个阵营。沙发派和非沙发派。有些人会说，面对面坐着交谈更容易。
And some people, some analysts, I could ever insist on not using the couch. They said they prefer sitting up. Richard hasn't really chosen a team. In his office, there's a couch and a chair. I do whatever it seems to, what works best for the patient. There may be a team couch and a team no couch, but even Freud wasn't that dogmatic about it.
有些人，一些分析师，甚至坚持不使用沙发。他们说他们更喜欢坐着。理查兹并没有真正选择阵营。在他的办公室里，有一张沙发和一把椅子。我做任何看起来对病人最有效的事情。可能存在沙发派和非沙发派，但即使是弗洛伊德也没有那么教条。
He had patients he treated on the couch and some he didn't, like the famous composer Gustaf Moller, whom Freud treated while strolling around the park. But here's the thing, while Freud wasn't dogmatic about using the couch, and while use of the psychoanalytic couch has declined, you wouldn't know it from popular culture. The analytic couch has become shorthand for therapy, particularly in one place. Hi, I'm Bob Mancoff, I'm cartoon editor of The New York Magazine. Bob Mancoff is surprisingly qualified to talk about this. Well, I have a background in experimental psychology.
他有一些在沙发上治疗的病人，也有一些没有，比如著名的作曲家古斯塔夫·马勒，弗洛伊德是在公园散步时为他治疗的。但问题是，虽然弗洛伊德在是否使用沙发的问题上并不教条，而且精神分析沙发的使用率已经下降，但你从流行文化中却看不出来。分析沙发已经成为治疗的代名词，特别是在一个地方。嗨，我是鲍勃·曼科夫，《纽约客》杂志的漫画编辑。鲍勃·曼科夫在谈论这个话题方面出奇地有资格。嗯，我有实验心理学的背景。
He wasn't a psychoanalyst exactly. I was an animal behaviorist, so to put little rats and pigeons on couch is extraordinarily difficult. Mancoff says the couch is fantastic as a symbol. It is just what a joke needs. I think the couch immediately establishes the power relationships here. The psychiatrist is in control. You are sort of helpless.
他并不是严格意义上的精神分析学家。我是一名动物行为学家，所以要把小老鼠和鸽子放在沙发上是非常困难的。曼科夫说，沙发作为一个符号非常棒。这正是笑话所需要的。我认为沙发立即确立了这里的权力关系。精神科医生掌控一切。你有点无助，
Childlike, lying on the couch. Even though real therapists aren't using the couch all that much, cartoonists still need it. When we look at the cartoons now, we do see that they're all on the couch. Of course, it's not just the New Yorker. We've seen the couch all over popular culture. Like, it's hard to imagine when he's Alan without the couch.
像孩子一样躺在沙发上。即使真正的治疗师并没有那么频繁地使用沙发，漫画家仍然需要它。当我们现在看漫画时，我们确实看到他们都躺在沙发上。当然，不仅仅是《纽约客》。我们在整个流行文化中都看到了沙发。比如，很难想象没有沙发，《安妮·霍尔》会是什么样。
You've been seeing a psychiatrist for 15 years. You should smoke some of this. You'd be off the couch in no time. And then there's the sopranos. Tony's soprano spends a lot of time with his therapist. And even though he's always sitting in a chair, when the camera pans out, there is a very typical brown analytic couch in the background.
“你看了15年的精神科医生。你应该抽点这个。你很快就能离开沙发了。”还有《黑道家族》。托尼·索普拉诺花了很多时间与他的治疗师在一起。尽管他总是坐在椅子上，但当镜头拉远时，背景里有一张非常典型的棕色分析沙发。
As if the set designer wanted to reassure our subconscious about what he was doing there. And when I asked Mancoff to imagine having to make New Yorker therapy jokes without the couch as a device? Oh, don't make me cry. Oh. I've made Bob Mancoff cry, I would just like to... I can't believe it.
好像布景设计师想让我们的潜意识对他在那里做的事情感到放心。当我问曼科夫想象一下如果没有沙发作为道具，该如何创作《纽约客》的治疗笑话时？哦，别让我哭。哦。我把鲍勃·曼科夫弄哭了，我只是想……我简直不敢相信。
I can't believe it was the couch. It was the couch. Okay. No, I mean, not while I'm running this thing. Thousands of people have made pilgrimages to see Freud's couch. It's a relic to how Freud revolutionized how we understand the human mind. The couch, especially Freud's couch, it came to symbolize an invitation to open your mind.
我不敢相信竟然是沙发。是沙发。好吧。不，我的意思是，不是在我经营这个节目的时候。成千上万的人曾朝圣般地去参观弗洛伊德的沙发。它是弗洛伊德如何彻底改变我们对人类心灵理解的遗物。沙发，尤其是弗洛伊德的沙发，象征着一种敞开心扉的邀请。
You know, to let someone see inside. That's Freud's color, Michael Roth again. It's a reminder that we have the ability to reveal ourselves. And that's irresistible, right? I mean, it's like a magic carpet. I can get on the couch and suddenly I'll say things that reveal what I really love.
你知道，让别人看到你的内心。那是弗洛伊德的颜色，迈克尔·罗斯再次说道。它提醒我们有能力揭示自己。这让人无法抗拒，对吧？我的意思是，它就像一张魔毯。我可以躺在沙发上，突然间我会说出揭示我真正热爱的东西的话。
Because my whole life I've been pretending to love other things. But I get on the cash and suddenly I say, my mother, she ruined my life. Not my mother. Look. You should say that again, make sure on my. Not my mother, she hears this story, she killed me.
因为我一生都在假装热爱其他东西。但我躺在沙发上，突然我说，我的母亲，她毁了我的生活。不是我母亲。看。你应该再说一遍，确保……不是我母亲，如果她听到这个故事，她会杀了我。
Michael Roth loves his mother, but if he didn't, and he does, it might be revealed on the couch. Freud has given us the ed, the ego, the super ego, the Freudian slip, a whole number of complexes, but beyond creating a vocabulary of the mind, he gave us a place to rest, the felidies. To share our desires, our inhibitions, our dreams, a place just to lie down and talk. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Anne Heperman With Katie Mangle, Sam Greenspan, Avery Trophiman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced are the offices of Arxan, an
迈克尔·罗斯爱他的母亲，但如果他不爱（他确实爱），这可能会在沙发上被揭露出来。弗洛伊德给了我们本我、自我、超我、弗洛伊德式口误，以及许多情结，但除了创造一种心灵的词汇外，他还给了我们一个休息的地方，一个分享我们的欲望、抑制、梦想的地方，一个可以躺下来交谈的地方。《99%隐形》本周由安·赫珀曼制作，凯蒂·曼格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特罗菲曼和我罗曼·马尔斯参与。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Arxan建筑与室内设计公司办公室制作。
architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook or on Twitter, Instagram, Tumblr and Spotify R-E-I-D-R-K. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook、Twitter、Instagram、Tumblr和Spotify上找到并点赞这个节目。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。